so uh here's what i'm trying to figure
out greta thunberg
has been uh going around the u.s and
europe
lecturing everybody about climate change
and um
uh and this is what environmentalists do
right they wag their fingers and they
lecture and they yell at us and
and that's their main and sometimes they
do like we talked about yesterday
sometimes they'll go into the middle of
the street
uh on a work day during rush hour to wag
their fingers
uh or as was the case yesterday even to
wag their butts you know is what they
were doing in the streets yesterday
uh they're wagging something though to
to tell us that climate change is a
terrible thing
um but they always seem to be focused
here's here's the thing that i don't
understand they always seem to be
focused
on the us and europe
um have you noticed that that's where
all of the focus
seems to be they train their ire and
their contempt
on us and that's kind of strange isn't
it
because you know according to some
theories
there are actually other countries in
the world
now i can't confirm this um i can't
confirm that there are other countries
i've never been to them
and the flat earthers tell me that uh
the world is is is a much smaller and
flatter place than
than you might imagine so i don't know
but
according to uh my research there is
this place called
asia asia exists okay
and um asia not only exists but it
it it in fact is by far by far
by far the biggest problem when it comes
to carbon emissions and pollution
as noted in an article in forbes china
alone
emits more carbon dioxide than the us
and europe combined
okay and it's not just because they have
more people either they do have more
people they've got
uh 1.3 billion people the u.s and europe
together have i don't know a billion 1.1
billion
but that extra 0.2 or 0.3 billion that's
not going to account for their carbon
contributions they're they're they're
doing more than their fair share of the
work here as far as
as far as making the war the climate
warmer um if you
you know if in fact that is what's
happening
i mean the air pollution in china is so
bad that their solar panels don't work
because there's so much pollution the
the light cannot penetrate through the
pollution to get to the solar panels
that's how bad it is in china
and not only that it's not just air
pollution most of the most polluted
rivers
in the world are in asia the top five
five
of the the five of the top five most
polluted rivers are in asia and that's
why a handful of asian countries like
four or five asian countries
are dumping more plastic into the river
than the rest of the world
combined okay you want to know how bad
the water pollution in asia is
i want to take a look at this picture
look at this picture right here um
here's a picture of
this is a picture of the uh satarum
river in indonesia all right it's a
sataram river in indonesia
and if you're listening right now and
not watching and you can't see this
it is a picture of essentially a
floating garbage not essentially
it's literally a floating garbage dump
is this a river it's a time it's the
most polluted river in the world
um and and by the way i got that picture
from a houston chronicle article which i
tell you not just to give them credit
but also because
the the uh the story attached to that
picture
is kind of interesting it's a story
about um an indonesian fisherman
who was out in the river fishing in that
river if you can imagine it
um and uh he thought that he had hooked
on a really big fish but it turns out to
be a dead human body
okay not a joke so this is bad this is
this is this is very bad these rivers
are very bad
and um it just makes you wonder
why we aren't including asia
in this discussion now they get
mentioned every once in a while it's
kind of like an honor
honorable they get an honorable mention
as
as contributors to pollution and climate
change but they're not honorable mention
they are number one
so i say again okay when it comes to
carbon emissions and water pollution
is the two biggest climate catastrophes
or climate problems that we hear about
by far the biggest problem comes from
asia
the water pollution thing is so bad that
actually you know the united states
could could um from here on out
produce no more pollution we could we
could stop
forever using plastic straws plastic
bottles
we could stop with all plastics and and
we could convert the entire country to
the disposable paper recyclable stuff
and it would make almost no difference
to the water pollution problem it would
make
almost no it would be like a thimble a
literal thimble in the ocean
because of what asia is doing
um so why why aren't they
getting not only mentioned more but why
aren't they getting the lion's share of
the blame
when they deserve it why is that well i
think it's because
a lot of this stuff is just posturing
and posturing isn't fun
and it isn't as politically expedient
when you do it in asia
okay um can you imagine now now the
the uh optics
of a 16 year old child yelling
at a bunch of white people a 16 year old
white child
white child yelling at a bunch of white
people about climate change now with
that
the media says oh she's look at her
she's
so courageous and brave now that 16 year
old white girl
were to go to asia and be yelling at a
bunch of asians
now all of a sudden it it changes the
picture
and so that's why they don't do it but
it really does call into question the
basic sincerity
of most of the climate alarmists that
they are training all of their fire
on precisely the countries who are
not only not contributing the most to it
but we're also the countries who are
at least taking this seriously
with asian countries it doesn't seem
like they're even it doesn't seem they
care at all about this
so if we're talking about raising
awareness we we
you've got that's covered here we've got
it covered we're all aware and a lot of
people are worried about it
and we are taking some steps at least
but in some of these asian countries
particularly china we haven't even
gotten to the raise awareness level yet
so why aren't we over there doing that
interesting question i want to talk more
about this but first um
a word from our good friends at noom
what if you could use
one program for all your health and
weight loss needs no more hunting for
training apps and workouts or calorie
trackers meal plans all that stuff
plus you get a goal specialist and a
community of members to keep you
motivated and accountable
so it's like having a workout partner um
and having that
the specialist and all of that all in
one place all together you know for me
my biggest challenge is eating healthy
um
that is a big problem for me staying on
task making the right choices
knowing what choices to make that's hard
for me and that's why i use
noom and and for me the benefits are not
just physical but psychological because
you feel better
and it's hard to put a price tag on that
nume is a habit-changing solution that
helps helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food
through personalized courses it's all
about it's all about adjusting
you know the way you not only eat
but the way you think about nutrition
and food
based in psychology noom teaches why you
do the things you do and it arms you
with the tools to break the bad habits
and replace them with better ones
you don't have to change it all in one
day small steps make a make a big
difference
sign up for your trial today at noom
n-o-o-m
dot com slash walsh what do you have to
lose aside from all the weight
visit noom.com walsh to start your trial
today that's noom.com
walsh the last weight loss program
you're ever going to need
okay speaking of um of greta thundberg
the 16 year old girl selected by the
media as we've been talking about to be
the poster child of um of climate
alarmism
she was you know
giving another hysterical speech on
monday at the u.n
and this time she declared
that the earth is undergoing a quote
mass extinction
which she warns probably can't be
averted we're probably screwed anyway i
know you've probably seen this by now
her speech but i'll play it for you
anyway and then we'll talk about it
watch this
this is all wrong i shouldn't be up here
i should be back in school on the other
side of the ocean
yet you all come to us young people for
hope
how dare you you have
stolen my dreams in my childhood with
your empty words
and yet i'm one of the lucky ones
people are suffering people are dying
ecosystems are collapsing we are in the
beginning
of a mass extinction and all you can
talk about
is money and fairy tales of eternal
economic growth
how dare you okay so how dare you
she says how dare you you've stolen my
dreams in my childhood on one level i
can i can relate to this sentiment
because it's exactly what i said after i
watched the lion king remake
it's exactly what i said to disney how
dare you you have stolen my dreams and
my childhood
um on another level though as a parent
i i find this girl very hard to watch
and what i mean is that um it's
difficult to watch because it's obvious
that she really believes her delusional
doomsday fantasies
and it's not it's not because it's not
her
fantasies right these are she is she's
repeating
what she's been told by the adults
around her who should know better
that's what makes it hard to watch um we
can have some fun with some of this
stuff but uh you can't help but you
can't help
but but have a little fun with some of
the climate alarmism because it's so
absurd but
when it comes to this particular girl
um she this is she's a child abuse
victim
that's what we're seeing now as the
media likes to remind us
thunberg is autistic and ocd
there's a there was a daily beast
profile done about her and
it um it very celebratory profile of
course
and let me read a relevant portion of
this profile from the daily business
says
but thanks to the formal diagnosis of
asperger's syndrome coupled with high
functioning autism and obsessive
compulsive disorder the now 16 year old
swede has become
quite literally the poster child for the
generation that will have to deal with
the destruction of our planet
once she started receiving multi-faceted
treatment funenberg was able to channel
her anxiety into something we should all
be concerned about
the health of the planet and the science
behind apocalyptic warnings of its
demise
in october 2018 thunberg started having
anxiety-ridden
3am nightmares but unlike before they
were not about her the recurring
nightmares were about the impact of
global warming on the planet according
to the book
scenes from the heart she wrote with her
parents and her sister bieta
who also suffers from many of the same
emotional conditions this time instead
of instead of holding up in her bedroom
as she did before the treatment
she decided that her anxiety about the
climate needed to become everyone else's
too
one of her one aspects of one of the
aspects of her complicated diagnosis is
obsession her family says
she wouldn't let the idea go to the
planet uh let the
the idea go that the planet was burning
up and there was ample science to prove
it
okay so the daily beast recounts all of
this
like we shouldn't be concerned about it
they recount it kind of matter
of factly or even approvingly
but what we're being told is that an
obsessive
um troubled young girl someone who's
who's been dealing with say recurring
nightmares
anxiety written i mean these are the
words being used in the daily beast
profile
and we're being told that a woman that a
child like that
came to believe mistakenly that the
apocalypse is upon us
that is a mistake okay the human race is
not in the midst of a mass extinction
and it would be nice if some of the
brave courageous media
fact checkers would maybe step up to the
plate and do a fact check of that
because that's just not the case
but that's what she came to believe and
and they even tell us they tell us that
she was
you know she she'd already been prone to
this kind of anxiety
and and and um and this is sort of
paranoia about things
um but but uh she started to
to to redirect that anxiety in the
direction of of this this global warming
stuff
which means that it's inevitable that
somebody who you know with that tendency
when they start to worry about something
they're going to worry
obsessively about it and they're going
to worry overly much about it i i should
know because
i have i haven't been diagnosed with
anything but uh but i i am no stranger
to anxiety myself
i'm no stranger to paranoia not about
the climate but about other things
and um and so i should know that you
know when when i get it into my head
to worry about something i i can't worry
about it a little bit
for me it becomes this obsessive and
then i start
in my head i start i start extrapolating
and i build this whole
nightmare scenario that i then start
worrying about
and i think that's how anxiety works for
a lot of people and it gets even worse
if you have an anxiety disorder
or whatever else um the point is
rather than go to this girl and
calm these fears and redirect her in
in a healthier direction and say to her
listen yeah you know it's good that we
want to protect the planet
and and it's good that you want to do
but but you're not going to die
okay the world's not coming to an end
it's going to be okay rather than go to
her and say this
the adults in her life have only
encouraged her paranoia
and now the media is only too happy to
exploit her fear in order to stoke even
more fear
creating fear with fear that's the media
specialty
this i say again is child abuse
if any grown-up in the thunberg's life
really cared about her psychological and
emotional well-being
they would sit her down and they would
explain to her that climate change is
not going to destroy human civilization
yes the climate is changing climates
tend to do that climates always change
they have sense
there ever was a climate you know ever
since there's been a climate or an
atmosphere on earth
um it has changed in it wildly it is it
is fluctuated
in in extremes and it was doing that
before there was even a
human beings on the planet so
um and they would explain that to her
and they would explain that uh
that you know whatever role humans have
played in that process
and yeah we probably have played some
role but it's highly debatable how much
of a role we've played
and it seems to me that that that in
comparison to other things that drive
the climate such as the sun
and the cycles of the sun our role is
minuscule
it would seem to me um but whatever the
case you know uh uh
it's it's not going to result in the end
of all life as we know it
talk of a 10-year 12-year 20-year
timeline before planetary catastrophe
is an invention of politicians and media
personalities this is not how scientists
speak
you're not going to find a credible
scientist anywhere
who will who will endorse this idea that
12 years from now the world's going to
come to an end
you're not going to hear that um
this is what would be told to greta
thundberg if if any of the adults in her
life really cared about her
when i was a child they told us about an
imminent future
where there wouldn't be any rainforests
well now i'm
living in that imminent future a future
that i was told would not have rain for
us
and there are rainforests and actually
by the way the rainforests are doing
pretty well they're on the rebound
um sure there was a problem with
deforestation sure we don't we don't
want to
cut down trees for no reason we don't
want to just um
you know recklessly destroy uh
forests and rainforests that's true
but the disto the dystopian vision of
the world
this vision of a world without trees was
and i couldn't have known this at the
time because i was a child
completely insane so it is possible to
say
hey listen trees are good and we
shouldn't just destroy them recklessly
without also adding oh and by the way
soon all the trees will be gone and
we're all going to suffocate
but the environmental alarmists they
always tack on that apocalyptic bit
at the end undermining the validity of
their own message and creating
unnecessary panic
so once again i think we have to call
this was it what it is it is child abuse
not just child abuse of greta thunder
but child abuse of all children
who are being told this stuff and are
being scared to death
about it and are being are being uh you
know traumatized and terrified
with these uh with these claims of of of
the end of the world
um coming upon us it may be a smart
political move to traumatize children
this way
but it is morally atrocious
so yeah go ahead and tell kids to
recycle tell them to pick up trash to
plant trees all of that that's all fine
that's worthwhile that's good
but the hysteria is unjustified and
wrong let kids be kids
they shouldn't have to wake up every
morning with hallucinatory fears about
the planet's demise
when i hear about a child waking up in
at three o'clock in the morning
with fears of of the end times
i don't think oh isn't that nice how
wonderful
i think that's terrible
uh that child needs help
that's what i would do for my child if
my child was waking up at three in the
morning my my kids might wake up
sometimes with night nightmares
if they're waking up every single night
with a nightmare about about about the
end of the world
i would go and try to get them help
that's no way to live
and it's also not true okay it's not
true there
there is no it that is not a credible
claim we can debate the degrees and
and all of that of of what how exactly
humans contribute to the problem of
climate change but the pop the
apocalyptic stuff
is is click bait it's political
manipulation it it's it's hysteria it's
it's hype you know it's all those things
it's not science that is not
science all right um
one other thing that's not that
important at all but i wanted to mention
it uh certainly not as important as the
as the apocalypse a few days ago it was
reported that marvel is considering
their casting for their new x-men movie
i guess and they're considering casting
denzel washington as
magneto in the new x-men film
magneto is uh if you're not um if you're
not
into comic book movies because you're an
adult uh uh
magneto is is one of the villains in
x-men and he's played by
ian mc ian mckellen in in the original
x-men movie that came out in whatever
the early 2000s um
so now they're saying they're gonna have
they might have denzel washington and
and this news was was greeted with
applause
of course by most people because it's a
it's a it's a black actor being cast in
this project
and really can i just say finally
somebody is giving denzel washington his
big break i think it's about time this
guy's been at it for so long
playing bit parts you know more of a
character actor finally he's getting his
shot at the big time and so
on one level i can see how that is cause
for celebration
but on the on another level this is also
i think a perfect example
of the hypocrisy of identity politics
because magneto
although he's a fictional character he
is supposed to be a jewish holocaust
survivor and this is a crucial aspect of
his backstory it's not a small detail
this is a big part
now i'm no x-men expert but um
i think anyone who is will agree with me
right that magneto holocaust jewish
holocaust survivor
this is a really crucial important
central aspect of his character that
speaks to his motivations and
everything else and i think that's how
he became
wasn't it that's how he became magneto
was through some nazi experiment i could
be wrong about that part don't quote me
okay that might be non-canonical but um
at the very least it's it's a big part
of his character i know that okay
um well
now they're talking about either
casting a black american as a german jew
or which would be totally absurd or
they would be erasing that backstory
entirely for the sake of class
casting a black american in that role
here's the thing this is
exactly the kind of thing that if done
in the reverse
prompts outraged cries of whitewashing
and appropriation and the rest of it
i mean can you imagine can you possibly
imagine
if they did a shaft remake and rather
than having samuel
samuel jackson reprise his role as shaft
um like he did in the in the shaft movie
that came out back you know in the early
2000s or where whenever it was
imagine if rather than than samuel l
jackson
they had some white guy playing shaft
can you possibly conceive
of the outrage that would follow i
really believe there would be there
would be
riots in the street i really think there
would be i'm not even exaggerating
am i wrong they whitewash shaft
and and give that roll to a white guy
there would be riots you would there
would be
over that that's how upset the woke mob
would be
uh and you can't say well it's all about
representation
tell me how many black characters are
there in the in the
uh comic books universe the the film
comic books universe
compare the number of black characters
and black actors of which i think there
are many
to how many jewish characters there are
because i is magneto like the only one
as of right now so you're talking about
taking that away
that jewish character away but it's just
it it
it doesn't it's of course why i even
pointed out at this point but it's
entirely hypocritical and inconsistent
and it just
look either this stuff matters or it
doesn't right
either it matters that we remain
uh that characters and how they're
portrayed remain racially
and ethnically consistent for the sake
of representation and all that kind of
stuff
either that matters or it doesn't
now look if we're all going to agree
that it doesn't matter because these are
fictional characters
and and you know you there can be
different versions of them
and the main thing is just to find an
interesting actor who can play that role
and hey maybe changing it up sometimes
can be kind of fun just to see what else
you can do with it
if that's our attitude then fine i'm all
on board for that
in that case let's do it i'm all if if
that's what we're going to say
then fine make magneto black make make
james bond into a into a woman
do whatever you want you know make
indiana jones into a
into a 13 year old chinese girl you know
whatever
but then
you can't stop there because then also
if we take a black character make them
white make them hispanic whatever then
you can't complain about that right it's
because if that's the approach
if we're all going to agree to that then
i say
great i think that's perfectly
reasonable because these are fictional
characters after all and we all
we all are taking this way too seriously
but what we can't do is say
when it pertains to uh characters of a
certain skin pigmentation then it
doesn't matter if you switch them up
but if they have different pigmentation
then it does now see that doesn't make
any sense
we can't do that that's not that doesn't
work that's insane
so it matters or it doesn't which one is
it as far as i can tell right now what
we've agreed on is that it does matter
and so this matters actually not my not
by my rules
not by my rules but by the rules that
have been established it really matters
and it is therefore an
outrage that they're talking about um
giving denzel washington this role all
right uh mattwall show at gmail dot com
mattwall showba
gmail.com is the email address
we will go to uh emails then this is
from
scott and i guess a little bit of
background here we we've been talking
about
well the conversation has developed in
the in the email portion but
uh a few days ago somebody wrote to the
show
talking about you know why do young
people leave the church
um and why is it so in some churches
that nominate denominations it's as high
as 80 or 90 percent of young people
but no matter what church you're looking
at it is a high percent a troubling
percentage of
young people leaving the church question
was why is that i think there are a lot
of reasons
one of the answers i gave is that i
think
there are a lot of young people coming
up in the church as they get older they
start to
think of difficult but still very good
and valid
questions theological questions moral
philosophical questions scientific
questions that all
revolve around this question around god
and christianity and faith and all these
things
and and because our churches are not
dealing with these very
serious mature adult theological
philosophical questions and instead most
churches are just giving you self-help
lectures every every sunday
because of that young people are you
know they're going on the internet
they're going on youtube they're going
elsewhere to find those answers
and um and then eventually they decide
based on the answers that they found
that oh what you know what i don't
believe this anymore
and my solution is one solution you know
not the solution but one thing we could
do
an important step is our churches could
start
dealing with some of these questions
start
um encouraging and and facilitating
serious study of not just the bible but
but the moral and philosophical
questions surrounding faith
and parents should be doing this too
with their kids
and maybe that's one thing we could do
to
raise up a generation of serious-minded
christians who are not
going to necessarily have to go to
youtube or whatever to find answers to
these questions because they're going to
find them in church they're going to
find them in their home
that was my my thing and then i got an
email yesterday from someone saying
that um well i'm totally wrong in what
i'm in in my assessment of the problem
because actually
if somebody leaves the faith if they
decide at the age of 20 or 30 or 40 or
50
that they actually don't believe and
they leave
then that means that they were never
christian to begin with
because according to the person that
emailed yesterday
it's impossible if you ever actually
really believe
in the gospel then you could never not
believe it you could never make the
choice to not believe it
you could never decide you don't believe
it you can't you believe it you believe
that's it
um and this doctrine has many names
persevere perseverance of the
the saints uh once saved always saved
you knows various slogans to but that's
the
the the basic idea got a lot of emails
about that from people defending this
doctrine
and so i'll read just one of them and
respond to this is from scott
says matt you are unbiblical in your
assessment of someone leaving the faith
especially in your response to the
emailer who disagreed with you
you used a lot of i think statements but
not once
referenced any sort of scripture in your
response frankly it doesn't matter what
you think about it or what i think about
it
you basically strawman his entire
response into shrugging off
doubts people have about christianity
but that's not what he said you accused
him of calling anyone with questions or
doubts
a fake christian and that's not what he
said he said those who leave the faith
were never believers to begin with
so there lies the question well that and
that's not you see ironically you're
strong manning me
i didn't say that he said that everyone
with doubts is a fake christian
i said that what he's saying is that
anyone who had doubts
and then comes to the conclusion i think
mistaken conclusion that christianity is
false
was therefore never a real christian was
always fake
and their entire 20 30 40 years
experience of being a christian is
invalid
that's what i accused him of saying
which is exactly what he said and
exactly what you're saying
and my point is that among other things
not only is that wrong
but it has the effect of just chasing
these people further away from the truth
what do you think it's going to do when
you're when you're telling someone that
they're 40 years when you're trying to
read their mind
and tell them that what they thought
they believed for 40 years they never
actually believed
and their whole experience of 40 years
of being a dedicated christian wasn't
real
why should they listen to anything else
you have to say you're tr
you just have you have no basis to make
that declaration it comes off as
extremely pretentious
and arrogant um and uh and and that's my
point
okay i don't know i think it's i think
it's a strong man that's i am addressing
head on
your claim and i'm telling you that in
in no offense meant i just think that
it's
that it it it does come off as as
pretentious and arrogant
don't take it from me okay take it from
the people who have left the church talk
to them
ask them what kind of response they got
from other christians and they're going
to tell you that they got this a lot
well you need to do is you were never a
real christian to begin with again
that is what you're saying scott you're
saying if someone leaves they were never
a real christian
isn't that what you're saying i just
read it and that's what miles said
and uh before we even get to whether or
not that's true which it isn't but
talking about you know how helpful is
that
to say to people who who who do leave
the faith
uh but maybe could be brought back in
that should be our goal right to bring
them back in
is it gonna are are we gonna do that if
we tell them that their whole experience
of 40 years was
was untrue and valid illegitimate not
real
all right let me go back i'm sorry to
interrupt i'm going to read your whole
email um
okay so
uh regarding eternal security this back
is back to scott um
the bible is very clear about it second
corinthians
5 17 describes us as a whole new
creation when saved not the same person
you cannot go back to your previous self
if you were in fact saved
ephesians 1 13-14 says we are sealed
some version says
guaranteed by the promise of the holy
spirit
even john 3 16 which everyone knows
says those who believe in him have
eternal life
there are many others of course but
these are clear to show that one who is
saved is marked for eternity
if we can walk away from the faith and
lose salvation then those passages are
all lies
we were not made into new creations we
were not sealed and we did not have
eternal life if there is a chance of
losing it again
all that said someone who leaves the
faith was never a brother or sister
of christ to begin with okay so that is
what you're saying right that's
that's what i said you said that's what
i said miles said yesterday and that is
what you're saying
first john 2 2 19 addresses those who
stopped continuing in the faith
and clearly says they were never of the
faith to begin with in matthew 7 21-23
jesus also says many will believe they
are saved
but they are they never were these
passages show that salvation is not
something we can lose it also shows that
there are many people who may even fool
themselves into believing they are born
again but they're not
those who leave the faith fall into that
category one who has doubts is natural
we all have doubts at some point but a
follower of christ will understand
that their human understanding is
inferior to god's perfect ways and the
correct answers are out there
those who isaiah 55 8 is what he quotes
or doesn't quote but references those
who trust their own understanding over
god are showing they are never
they they never believed him to be the
ultimate savior and lord of their life
one who allows doubt to grow into
disbelief was never sealed or it
wouldn't have been
able to pull them away you mentioned the
idea of a 40-year christian who leaves
the faith
since the bible is clear and eternal
salvation only two options remain for
that individual
either the person is still saved even
though he rejects and curses god or the
person never understood god his
character and the gift of salvation
which one of those is more likely
christians need to do a better job of
addressing questions and doubts when
they arise in our own lives or in the
lives of those in the church body
the devil will use anything possible to
get us to question god's nature
going all the way back to the garden a
bible believer will go to the to the
word with these questions as god has
revealed himself
to those who seek him james 4 8 psalms
119. okay um so there's
scott uh uh sorry scott i
again i don't think i straw manned him
at all or i'm not gonna strawman you
um he said it's impossible for anyone
who once believed to not believe anymore
i find that proposition absurd
um frankly and
yes i'm aware that lots of christians
agree with him
but i think it is a false doctrine um
and it does a lot of harm in a lot of
ways
that's my view you say i didn't give any
scripture passages that's true
you gave some uh you didn't actually
quote most of them you just
you just threw out the verses uh which
which which is a tactic i notice
christians can do sometimes where they
say oh the bible supports me on this and
they throw out a verse
well especially if it's a verbal
conversation you know the person's not
gonna sit there and look it up right
there so they have to just take your
word
for your interpretation of it i think
it's important if you're gonna throw out
verses to actually give the verses
um i think what you're doing here is is
proof texting
okay i think you have a doctrine in mind
that you want to support and so you're
skimming through the text to find a
verse here and there that seems to prop
it up
the problem is that any doctrine can be
supported that way
any doctrine the the going all the way
back to the beginning go back
going back to to uh you know uh uh think
about the
the council of nicaea in the year 313
think about the the aryans who believe
that
that that jesus christ was not eternally
begotten of the father is not is not one
in substance with a father but was
actually a created being
okay um did they had they had verses
they could cite they had a lot of verses
they could cite to to prove
quote unquote that assertion
they could do their own proof texting i
mean they could go to jesus saying why
do you call me good there's only one
that's good
god the father now in a vacuum that
would seem to be jesus
distinguishing himself from god the
father and saying he's you know god's
good
don't call me that because that's god
that's not me
but once we look at the totality of the
gospel then we start to understand that
one in context you see that's the danger
of proof texting
um and that's why i'm just i and that's
one of the reasons why when i when i
address these issues
i i try to look at it
to take a general view of
what we're being told in the gospels and
in in
in in what the you know in in christian
tradition
because i know that if i just you can't
just take one verse and say well there
you go
because anyone can do that for anything
you see that's the problem you have to
you have to wrestle with that
um and this is one of the reasons why
our our our debates within christianity
never get anywhere
because everyone has their two or three
verses there are two or three favorite
verses to prop
up whatever doctrine they like and they
just we just throw them at each other
like a food fight
and we all go home believing what we
believed before and
what we believe um is probably not what
we learned from scripture study now i i
don't know scott
i could be wrong with this talk about
presumptuous this is a presumption of my
product could be wrong but
i think it seems highly likely that this
idea of eternal salvation once saved all
be saved
that you you didn't get that from
scripture study you were told that
growing up and then you were given the
verses that supposedly support it
and i i i think that's an important
distinction i could be wrong you know
but i i think that's
where a lot of people get their
doctrines doesn't mean the doctrines are
wrong
it just means that at a certain point
you got to go back
and look at it again now
one thing um and here's one thing that
leads me to that conclusion
is that you say the scripture is very
clear
but you're saying the scripture is clear
about a doctrine that didn't really
exist in any significant form in in
christian tradition
until the calvinist came up with it 1500
years after christ was crucified
now yeah it's true that augustine you
know
had had what you make said said
a few things that you may call a sort of
almost
proto version of that but not exactly
um but it is just a fact of christian
history that this
idea of eternal security once saved all
we say this was not a doctrine that
existed in any significant way
for about 1500 years
and it's a doctrine of the vast majority
of christians today and throughout
history from the beginning
have either outright rejected or never
even heard of
now doesn't that mean that it that it
isn't true
necessary now okay it doesn't mean that
it isn't true
but doesn't that mean that it probably
isn't as clear
as what you're saying all you have to do
is look at the history of christianity
and i think an appreciation of its
history will lead you inevitably to the
conclusion
that this doctrine at a minimum
is unclear so i don't understand when
christians do this
they take some highly contested doctrine
that people have been
arguing about for centuries and they say
it's clear
well if it's so clear then why is
everyone arguing about it
unless you're suggesting that everybody
is stupid except for you and i don't
think you are suggesting that
but if you're not suggesting that then
you have to admit that it's at least
possible for sincere and intelligent and
faithful christians
to read the same text you're reading and
come to the opposite conclusion
and in fact billions of christianity
christians from the very beginning have
done just that
which means that your conclusion correct
or not
is not entirely clear so i would just
urge maybe
for all of us a little bit of humility
when we're dealing with these and i say
this to myself people when we're dealing
with these
highly contentious doctrines especially
ones that
as i said didn't really exist for about
1500 years
you might say they existed because
they're in the gospels or they're in the
you know the end they're in the they're
in the epistles which is mostly what you
mentioned
um okay well at a minimum nobody had
noticed them for about 1500 years
which would seem at least means you
should pump the brakes on it's very
clear
okay now um so i could i could uh uh
i could throw verses at you too um
hebrews 10 26
for if we sin willfully after that we
have received the knowledge of the truth
there remains no more sacrifice for sins
but a certain fearful looking for of
judgment and fiery indignation
which shall devour devour the
adversaries hebrews 10 38
now the just shall live by faith but if
any man draw
back my soul shall have no pleasure in
him but we are not of them who draw back
unto perdition but of them that believe
to the saving of the soul
what i get from verses like this and the
dozens of others
like it is that a person can willfully
draw back after having come to believe
i could say just as well it's clear it's
right there in the verse
willfully draw back which seems to tell
me you could believe and then willfully
draw back because that's what it says
right um there is there's nothing in
those verses that supports one saved
always saved
unless you're determined to take the few
verses you mentioned
inter interpret them a certain way and
then interpret
every other verse through that lens but
here's the problem you're interpreting
all the rest of the verses through the
through the verse through the few verses
you cited
well how do you know that you're not
supposed to be interpreting those verses
through the lens of the verses that i
cited how do you know that
now you actually mentioned this you
mentioned matthew 7 21 um
although you didn't quote it let me
quote it not everyone that says to me
lord lord shall enter into the kingdom
of heaven
but he that does the will of my father
which is in heaven many will say to me
in that day
lord lord have we not prophesied in your
name and in your name have
cast out devils and in your name done
many wonderful works and then i will
profess to them
i never knew you depart from me you evil
doers
now this is very important because the
way that you
interpreted that is that you said what
jesus was saying is that yeah there are
a lot of people who thought they
believed and uh
and then it's gonna turn out that they
really didn't you know that's not what
he said though
that is not what he said there is no
version
of this verse that i'm aware of in any
translation anywhere
ever that says that
all of the translations either say evil
doers
or something like workers of iniquity
that's the king james version i believe
so he doesn't say depart from me you
never believed you just thought you
believed
he says depart from me because you did
the wrong thing
so he's talking about willful actions
workers of iniquity
evil doers now again
you have your doctrine in mind you have
those few verses you're interpreting it
through a certain lens
so you are determined to interpret that
as him really saying
that well the reason they did the wrong
thing is because they didn't really
believe
that's not what he actually said though
that's just the lens through which you
are viewing it
i think if you take him at his own word
it really seems like jesus is saying
there are people who basically are
christians but they did they do
evil and so they're not coming
taking them taking jesus at his own
words here that
seems to really be what he's saying
and then there's a lot of stuff like
this in galatians um it is freedom for
christ that christ has set us free stand
firm then and do not let yourselves be
burdened again by a yoke of slavery
why are we being told to stand firm why
are we being exhorted to stand
firm if standing firm is somehow an
automatic consequence of once having
been saved
why are there so many passages in the
bible telling us to stand
firm if we automatically do that with no
effort
and then there's this kind of thing like
in matthew and if your right hand causes
you to stumble cut it off and throw it
away it's better
to lose one part of your body than for
the whole body to go into hell i mean
that sounds an awful lot like an
injunction to believers
it sounds an awful lot like jesus is
saying this to people who already
believe
and now he's exhorting you he's telling
you commanding you
to be very careful and if you're sinning
to cut off this aspect of your life or
that aspect of your life
which really seems to suggest that you
could be a believer and still go to hell
um which also would really seem to
suggest that you could be a believer and
then stop being one
i mean why does jesus and this is my
point about looking at the totality of
scripture
why does jesus spend so much time giving
commands and exhortations to believers
if their continued belief and thus
salvation is already guaranteed what's
the point
it just doesn't seem like there's any
point to it in fact what's the point
about 90
of the bible considering that almost all
of it is directed to believers
and so much of it contains instructions
about what we should do to get on
and stay on the path to salvation
and this is why i don't want to just
throw verses at you what i'm saying is
look at the entire thing
i think your doctrine here has just
negated almost all of it because there's
no point of it
i'm sure you would say to christians
make sure you read your bible make sure
you stay strong in your faith
why though you just said it's automatic
now you might say well if you're really
a christian you'll want to read your
bible
okay well that's totally different
though i mean do you think christians
should is it something that
not do they want to should they
i think they should but why do you think
they should you're saying that
it's guaranteed you're going to heaven
nothing's going to change it nothing can
change it you can't even change it so
what's the point i mean
at a minimum it's it's you know yeah you
could read the bible or don't
you're going you're going to heaven
either way right according to you
um and by the way how did adam and eve
get kicked out of the garden of eden
they believed didn't they
they no no no no there's nothing in
there but in fact
there's nothing in there about belief at
all in fact in the entire old testament
there's almost nothing about belief it's
there's really no emphasis on belief
hardly at all in the old testament um
it's it's it's all about doing what you
do your willful
actions starting with the thing that
kicked it off in the garden of eden
they were in paradise physically they
changed their minds they lost it
what about satan satan was in heaven
he was in heaven already as an angel
changed his mind
so adam and eve can lose paradise satan
can lose heaven
but we can't change our minds it's
impossible
does that make any sense if one saved
always saved is true
then the fall could not have happened
the fact that the fall happened clearly
indicates
that we can be in christ
on earth on earth and then
leaf clearly indicates that
i mean you could say well why would if
you really believe why would god let you
leave
that's a good question why did you let
adam and eve leave why do you let satan
leave
that's an entirely different question
all i know is that he does let those
things happen
because that's our whole faith is based
on that
and then we get to the common sense
aspect of this and i gotta wrap this up
but um
common sense tells us that human beings
are perfectly capable
of believing something and really
believing with all their hearts and then
not believing it anymore
you know you are insisting not only
contrary to scripture but contrary to
the the collective experience of all
human beings
that we can't change our mind about
something like this yet we all know that
we can
you know and you still haven't accounted
for all the millions of people
who have changed their minds they
thought they believed when they didn't i
mean what does that even mean
what does that actually mean how can you
think you believe something
that you don't really believe can you
explain that
how can a person for 40 years thinks he
believes something
but then he doesn't believe it it turns
out he never believed it the whole time
he thought he believed it but he doesn't
isn't thinking you believe something
exactly the same as believing it
tell me the distinction between thinking
you believe something
and believing it i want you to define
that distinction i don't think you can
because i think it's exactly the same
now it's one thing to say he thought
something was true and then he thought
it wasn't
it's another thing to say he thought he
thought something was true
and then he realized he never thought it
i mean what does that does that even
make sense scott i
it doesn't make sense to me i can i
literally cannot make sense of that i
just i don't even know what that means
so that's part of my problem with this
whole you know the whole doctrine is
that i
it it seems logically incoherent
because you are proposing a state of
mind
that is impossible for a human you're
proposing a state of mind
where you at one level believe something
totally and completely and in another
level
not at all now this might be possible
for people with split brain syndrome but
for those of us with
with an intact fully functioning brain
um
it doesn't seem possible so it seems
that based on your reading of a few
bible verses you are discounting every
other bible
verse and along the way also discounting
the personal experience of millions of
people and proposing that you can speak
for their mental states better than they
can and at the same time you're
suggesting that the human mind can do
something namely accept and reject a
proposition
simultaneously that i think it really
cannot do
so that's my issue okay
um and i will i think i've said enough
on the topic of this i'd go for another
two hours if you want
if anyone's interested um all right but
but i do i do appreciate the emails and
uh and i do and these these are the
kinds of questions i mean really these
are the kind of questions that interest
me more than any of this political stuff
or climate change
i don't know if you can tell that but
that's why i spend most of my time on
this stuff
i just find it a lot more interesting um
so i appreciate
all of the feedback thanks everybody for
watching thanks for listening
godspeed the matt walsh show is produced
by robert sterling associate producer
alexia garcia del rio
executive producer jeremy boring senior
producer jonathan haye
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by donovan fowler
audio is mixed by mike coromina the matt
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019.
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
michael knowles show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics
and bask in the simple joys of being
[Music]
right